I'm a believer that when you build a
business based around you and what it is
that you believe in that there are no
real competitors out there sure if I
call myself a business coach for example
there might be other business coaches
out there that call themselves business
coaches as well but none of the other
business coaches are going to coach
business owners the way I do that makes
me unique so when you build the business
of you which we talk about in the book
there are no real competitors out there
it's a 100% original business likewise
because people fall in love with you
with your audience as an example they
love you and what you stand for and how
you help them if at some point in the
future you want to Pivot a little bit
and go in a slightly different direction
you will be future proof because those
hardcore subscribers and followers will
go with you they'll pivot with you
because it's not so much about the
content that Ally puts out it's actually
about Ally himself and that's the
definition of a personal brand business
owner being future proof